talented mr. Ripley welcome former Oscar
nominee cate blanchett and her
oscar-nominated co-star Jude Law
brevity is the soul of wit and the heart
of the live action short film as well as
our presentation for the award for the
best of the shorts this category also
contains the most interesting title of
any Oscar film this year here are the
nominees from Indore Tess and Niko
Henrik Ruben gents and Michael W host oh
no that one
Killing Joke Mehdi Neuros Ian and Steve
wax
plenty of small change back Andres Boca
and debris elements
know that one
major and minor miracles Marcus Olson my
mother dreams the Satan's disciples in
New York barber shop and Tammy - that's
the one and yesterday is - my mother
dreams the Satan's disciples in New York
barber shop and tomatillo this is the
first Oscar nomination for Barbara
Stockton Tammy teal this entry was
barbershops American filming
wheezes film
subject of this film my mother's in the
audience and I think she's probably
fainted we'd like to thank our
cinematographer Chris Manley Rex Pickett
for his wonderful screenplay
our lovely lead actress Helen Steinberg
my deepest thanks goes to our executive
producer and my husband John Martin for
helping me think straight making
everything possible and to my family and
friends who support has been so
unwavering I've dreamed of giving
something in return this is for my mom
and dad and for all the talented people
who helped us make this film thanks also
so much to the bikers who helped us out
and I'd like to personally thank my
family Bob and Pat teal my sisters my
grandmother's everybody who's watching
in Ridley Park my husband Bill Steadman
and Keith Smith and Rick Wiley thank you
so much thank you